but you know what though have you ever
read the book uh why do men love me oh
yeah that was written by a single author
that is still singing I
came around I saw that book in the house
and I just cut it off I was like you are
long that book is on my bedside table
that was my Bible a few years ago like
right next to her astrology set
you said you have been misled my dear
but you said you've never been in a
relationship so it doesn't work
it was pretty teeth
I've been in a relationship but like nah
like if you're not showing me how you
can protect me and how you can provide
me I'm not cooking you a meal get lost
why would but why would you be with that
guy in the first place
well fast but